Russia
has just announced its official support for Comoros
in order to recover
the island of Mayotte under French control.
This is the ambassador of Russia in Comoros
who announced it to the Comorian press
in an interview earlier this week.
The island of Mayotte is 1 Comorian island
who refused to join the union of the Comoros
during the independence of the country.
By choosing to stay with France,
the Comorian media have relayed
massively the words of Russia
for the recovery of Mayotte under French control.
The Comoros
do not exclude 1 military action of last resort.
President Putin promised the
Comorian President 1 diplomatic support from Russia
within the UN for the return of the island of Mayotte.
Russian words
were received with enthusiasm by the Comorians.
This is a new challenge for President Macron
which faces the offensive of Russian diplomacy
in the African continent
which is increasingly attracted to offers
diplomatic,
economic and military of Russia.
For more information and analysis,
feel free to follow info minutes
on all our networks.